this page is very important for all
those who have uh joined the program for
you to
uh go through the schedule keep a track
on what schedules uh what sessions do we
have scheduled on which particular dates
what are the associated resources and we
will also post the recordings of the
mentor guided sessions here on the
program page itself so it's very
important for you to keep a track on
this program page for the entire
duration of your and doing that
all right so today we had the first
session those who are asking about the
recording of the session the recording
of the session will be updated on the
program page in an hour or two just when
the processing of the recording is
complete we uploaded you can then access
the recording the program page can be
accessed by the program participants so
if you will have a badge on your profile
named as ken informatics for biomedical
drug discovery if you click on that
badge on your profile you will be
redirected to this program page i will
show it to you shortly or you can
directly access the page with the link
that i have shared in the chat i'll also
share this link by an email so you will
have this link with you where you can
access the recordings look what the
resources are that you have to follow
and find the links of the supplemental
material as well
so uh here we have the session schedule
that i was talking about today we had
the first session the next session is
scheduled for august 25th so we'll be
having sessions for this program on
every monday and every thursday all
right ah
today the first session was an
exceptional case where it was scheduled
for tuesday because we already had some
cliched sessions scheduled for yesterday
but otherwise you'll have these sessions
on mondays and thursdays to keep a track
of these sessions that's what i'm
telling you
then we have the third session on
chemical and protein databases on august
29th we have mentioned the topics here i
won't be going into much depth of
teaching empty topic for the sessions
that we would cover otherwise it will
take a long time
then we have the fourth session on
target structure prediction on september
1st target identification virtual
screening will cover on september 5th
experience and docking we'll have a
hands-on session for this on september
8th and and on september 12th we'll have
the session on data science and ai and
healthcare and we'll practice the our
collab notebook for the same
on september 13 we have a workshop on
alpha phone a two hour long workshop
where we are going to have a practical
hands-on iphone phone all right and this
is what it is mentioned in the program
as well this is a two-hour workshop
specifically on september 15th we have
the next session on recent advances in
blog discovery this this session will be
taken up by an industry academy export
and then you have the next session on ai
and molecular drug discovery on
september 19th the next session will is
scheduled for september 22nd on advanced
chem informatics
and then towards the end we'll be
discussing about how you can design a
chemi informatics research project and
get started all together and finally
discuss some case study examples of
successful and failed drug development
by industry experts who were involved in
these successful and failed drug
development processes all right so that
is what is the schedule of this program
you can find it on the program page and
today was the first session and we
invited also the
participants who were entrusted to
enroll for the program as they wanted to
get some insights how the session would
be conducted today was a much
introductory session because we wanted
to get you all started and introduce you
to all the resources so that you don't
skip any one of these please make sure
that you join the skype group because
that is the way we can stay connected
every time yes mail is also a very good
option where you can mail us on support
at the refine dot bio and connect with
us for any query but joining skype will
also keep on updating you about the
sessions recordings
resources supplementary materials that
we share and also i have a chat with the
mentor regarding the questions that you
might have or ask for a
uh life zoom meeting to clarify your
questions all right so it would be very
helpful please try to download skype if
you're not there on skype create an
account we'll share the link with you
please join the community
all right
now for those who have not yet joined
the program and were here just to
get some insights on how the program
will be conducted and what the structure
of the program is but wish to continue
for the other sessions they have they
can register themselves for the program
uh we are accepting registrations till
tomorrow and here we have three
different subscription types that you
can pick and enroll for it's uh
completely on you which particular level
type you want to pick i'll just quickly
explain what these includes so these
different subscription levels are
specifically or will give you access to
the program and the resources for
different numbers of days that is what
it means the 45 days one will give you
the access to the whole training program
a point to be mentioned the resources
and all of these three different subs uh
different subscription level are the
same you'll get the same session
recordings and the uh supplementary
material as well
uh there is difference only in terms of
mental guidance and research work that
you uh do
or that you work on
so in the 45 days you will be able to
just complete the training program but
in 60 days as you will have some more
time you can meet the mentor
clarify your questions uh and also
discuss your research question that you
would like to work on design your
research hypothesis with the mentor in
these live sessions so it will be it
will include more of interactions with
the mentor where you can get all of this
done
and then the 90 days access that is the
advanced level uh subscription type you
will be able to complete a research
project along with the training part as
well
this is what i explained in the very
beginning of the session where i was
saying that the
participants who have taken up the 90
days of subscription you are required to
work on a research project so
uh the moment the training process is
complete the moment the training part is
complete all the sessions are covered
all the practical hands-on uh sessions
are completed and until then you will
have a good uh
idea about the concepts and you will
have some good hands-on practice as well
with these tools and software that we'll
be covering all right along with these
sessions what you can do is you can
start a literature review and at least
come up with the research question that
or maybe have some idea at least that
you would like to discuss with your
mentor
so uh you you can then i should do a
meeting with your mentor discuss your
idea what exactly you want to work on
and the mentor could uh help you frame
your question in the right manner or
modify a question it is required and
then you can get started to work on your
research project all right now what
would be the outcome of this research
project the very first thing is that you
will get to publish this project on the
on logic non-portal itself where you
will have this research publication that
you can share with your community or
future future recruiters or if you are a
student a graduate or a postgraduate
student and want to pursue higher
studies you could use this publication
for that as well you can present this
research work in any good uh conference
or symposiums in the poster presentation
uh format all right and definitely
proceed ahead to publish your research
work in a repetitive journal as well so
that could be the three different
outcomes of uh working on a research
project
that was it that i wanted to discuss now
it's up to you which a particular
subscription type you want to pick it
really depends on how many days do you
have your availability for to work or uh
to learn a new skill set in book on a
project
all right and also we are offering great
scholarships uh to students and
researchers so you can reach out to
spash uh on marketing on misogyny.com
and she'll be able to help you out with
uh the scholarship uh opportunities
she'll be able to tell you how much
scholarship can you get on the program
and uh also uh especially if you can
share scholarship form so the
participants can fill that out we'll
review your application and we'll get
back to you on the scholarship uh that
you can get for
joining the program
so that was it now we have some uh
messages in the chat box i would like to
address them
did i have explained 60 days so i think
that is clear to you uh yes definitely
you will get the certificate so where do
you get the certificates for the uh
courses that you complete and for the
program that you complete so when you
will complete all the sessions on the
program page that i just showed you
after the completion of all these
sessions on the program page you will
get a certificate automatically on your
profile under the programs tab uh let me
look for a program that i have completed
so that i can show it to you here it is
uh there was a program on introduction
to chemi informatics in the month of
april so i completed the sessions and
then you can move your certificate from
here and you can also download a
certificate directly from your profile
section itself
uh that was about certificates and also
along with each and every session as i
told you that you have to complete some
associated resources which are the
courses on the honest logic learn portal
itself so also for each and every
coursework that you complete you are
going to get uh the certificate that you
can download and share your achievement
on social media platforms and uh sparsh
has now shared the scholarship form in
the chat box thank you sparsh uh those
who are interested to avail the
scholarship please uh fill out the form
and our team will get back to you after
uh reviewing your application
uh z mehta uh you were asking about how
bioinformatics can help you in your
further studies
uh so for that uh it is first of all
very important as you are a biotech
student it's very important for you to
first of all know what the field of
bioinformatics is all about and identify
a research and trust all right so for
that you can go through the
bioinformatics coursework and bytes and
molecules on the misogyn portal these
two courses are free courses you just
need to create an account and directly
uh start with introduction to
bioinformatics and bytes and molecules
and these forces will give you a good
idea about what bioinformatics is all
about what is the role of bioinformatics
in health care
and
what are the different
types of big data or mixed data that the
researchers are now dealing with or
working on all right so it's a very
short course work which will help you
give a help you get a good understanding
and then you have the next coursework
that is bytes and
bytes and molecules which will help you
understand the different types of or
mixed data of types lcr fields like
genomics metagenomics transcriptomics
because you are a bsc biotech student i
know you are at a very early stage so
you can go through bytes and molecules
and get a good idea about what are these
different types of omnis data types and
what are the different specialization
tracks where these different ominous
data types have their applications and
uh what what type of data analysis is
involved and stuff so these are
introductory courseworks which are
definitely free of cost you can just
simply sign in and go through them and
identify your interest first like i
identify your interests which feel uh
interests you the most and then you can
take it further
and learn more about all right so uh
today we are talking about structural
biology or chemi informatics so there is
a basic coursework that has been
recommended for you all to get started
uh for today's session that is protein
structure and function
so you can both go through this
particular lesson where we have tried to
explain what are the different types of
protein structures and uh
also
how the
structural biology was evolved all
together and what are the basic concepts
um in one
all right and uh
cynthia you will get to know about the
bioinformatics stones uh for
uh computer aided drug designing
definitely all came informatics serious
tools and databases uh throughout this
program today our idea was just to
introduce you uh to these different
tools and databases now we will take
each one of them and dig more get uh
like
we uh in the upcoming sessions we are
going to uh get more uh insights about
each and every tool and software or
database we'll explore these databases
extract these structures from these
databases and then work on them using
these different types of tools and
softwares so today was just an
introductory session we did we wanted to
keep it light and not overwhelm you all
a lot with all these different types of
tools and databases and software's
working how do they actually work but
now we um try to
move from a bigger level to an advanced
level slowly
all right i think those were the
questions that we had in the chat box to
address
and if there are any other questions you
can please put in the chat uh oh cynthia
uh about the 60 days part uh so i said
that you have three levels 45 60 and 90
days 60 days means two months all right
so you will be completing the training
part in one and a half month and the
other half month or let's say 15 days
that you will have with you you can uh
discuss with the mentor uh your research
uh hypothesis all right you will get to
design a research project okay
and
to get started with it or to work on it
you definitely need an extension so a 90
days of project
will
uh definitely assure a publication of
a research publication but on a 60 days
if you take up a 660 day subscription
level it won't be easy for you because
in two months you can't complete the
training also and then work on a project
and get a complication that's
practically not feasible at all
so you will complete your training part
first and then do the literature review
come up with a question design your
hypothesis and then you start going on a
project so if you want to come up with a
publication a research publication
out of this program then maybe you can
take up the 90 days or the subscription
level and if you're seeking scholarship
this first can help you with that
uh so bridgette the first two courses
introduction to bioinformatics and bytes
and molecules are free courses because
these are introductory courses and there
are many people who come from different
fields they might not be from
bioinformatics they might be from
biotech or microbiology or biochemistry
or a completely different being like
biophysics altogether so these two
courses are for them to gets to know or
get introduced to
bioinformatics and different comics data
types reduced to data science and get
introduced to structural biology that is
why these two courses are free and then
to access the other courses you have a
license involved because in
other courses you have a data analysis
practical sessions involved as well
which require you to take up the access
of the t by info server where you uh
carry out all the practical hands-on
hands-on analysis and on the server you
will be allocated five terabyte of space
so for the space and the license it um
actually requires a specific fee to
maintain these particular spaces and
licenses that we are providing all right
so doctor courses after your first you
can both go through them and then
identify and uh i identify a research
interest and then take it further
i hope i was able to answer question
project and
do we have any further questions
all right thank you
so if we have no more questions uh we
can end today's meeting
thank you clement we can end today's
meeting and uh we'll be now meeting on
august 25th for the second session
i will be mailing out the recording of
the session the resources that you have
to go through
and the assignment that you have to
complete all right and also i will share
the link to join the skype group please
make sure that you join the skype group
if in case you face any technical issue
in joining please email us at marketing
at the economicslogic.com
and for the participants of the program
please make sure that you have an
updated profile we require you to have
an updated profile so that we can
monitor your progress all right briona
please make sure that you have an
updated profile and also the other
participants
okay that was it and um
you need to submit your assignment on uh
marketing address logic uh
only if you're not a program participant
if you are a program participant then
please email us on support gradebind.com
okay
that was it and uh hoping there are no
more questions as i can see in the chat
box we are good to end today's session
looking forward to meet you all on
august 25th have a nice day take care